i find the greatest bands are the ones
that don't sell out in other words
you could have changed your sound to a
more commercial sound
you know you could have been pressured
into that by a record company at any
point
someone could have said to you look this
isn't commercial and you say yeah [ __ ]
it let's just you know we'll write we'll
write a real commercial album
and we'll sell our sound out and you
never did it and that's why i think the
audiences still respond to you guys
i agree completely they see the honesty
in what you do
and at you know it's all relative
someone
we've heard that we've sold out a
million forever
right but it's all relative to what your
world is and how small your world is
so we've we've stayed honest to
ourselves
and that's all we can also all we can do
when did the sellout [ __ ] start when
the black album came out
way before that ride the lights on the
second album we had a song called fade
to black that we still play
almost at every show and um james
thought it would be a great idea to have
acoustic guitars
on the album right so when the metal
community heard
a metallica song with acoustic guitars
they all lost their [ __ ] lunches
big time this is the song you're talking
about there you go the big sell out
and to me this is 29 years ago it is one
of the most beautiful songs out there
i mean wow what a song
[Music]
well fade to black
[Music]
lars said the writing of this song that
that james you were obsessed with death
that this was your death obsession is
that true
uh still am somewhat i think there's a
fear of death that we all kind of
struggle with and battle with
i think at that point i remember writing
fade to black
uh everything was metal joe's
metal on metal joe's couch
metal joe you know metal joke no metal
joe
i don't know man joe infamous metal joe
he took us in when our manager
uh basically kicked us out of his house
and jersey yeah old bridge new jersey
1983
old bridge we lived out on his farm and
we just partied and
played and wrote songs and uh
i think at that point we were supposed
to go
we were supposed to go to europe for the
first time twisted sister
yeah and our gear had gotten stolen we
got the phone call
that not only was our well our our our
then
tour manager had a u-haul filled with
our gear
someone stole the whole u-haul it
doesn't get more depressing than that
when you're a band and your gear is
stolen you don't have the money
to replace you can't even we were lucky
that we
we had our guitars with us so it was so
cold in boston
that's where they got so so now you can
joke about it but at that point you were
so depressed
and all your gear was stolen and then
you start thinking about
jesus what the hell is life all about
and we're going to die anyway
more like our career is over we're
screwed we're you know and then you come
up with this yeah
gives me chills it's fantastic